The least
developed nation in Asia
is waiting for vital aid.
The U.N.
says Myanmar's military
junta is holding up
humanitarian access
to communities
devastated by cyclone muka.
Rescue groups are warning
of what they call a large scale
loss of life.
CNN has been speaking
to people
who saw their homes and loved ones
swept away in Sunday's storm.
Paula Hancocks brings us their story.
It was one of the strongest
cyclones to ever hit Myanmar
and it hit the most vulnerable
and desperate
Temporary shelters in this Rohingya
refugee camp were destroyed.
More than 400 people have died
and entire
villages have been wiped out,
according to eyewitnesses.
Those who survived
try to salvage
anything left of their homes.
And lay to rest.
Those who were lost to exhaustion already
lost his home once.
Fleeing religious persecution
by Myanmar's military
ten years ago, leaving everything behind.
He's now homeless again.
Let me just show you
the situation over here.
My home is completely destroyed.
Some of the people
have already clear my area.
He has been helping
search and rescue missions,
looking for the bodies of his neighbors
and helping to bury the dead.
My heart is very, very broken.
I don't know how to mention in what
but when I see the dead bodies,
I can't control my tears.
Myanmar's military
has been accused
of killing thousands of Muslim Rohingya
in a bloody and brutal crackdown.
It's been described by the United Nations
as a genocide.
About a million Rohingya
fled to neighboring
Bangladesh, starting in 2017.
But hundreds of thousands
still live here in Myanmar.
Many displaced
and in dire need of humanitarian aid.
Abdul Hussein says he saw his wife
and three daughters
swept away by the water
as they tried to flee to safety.
Honey, let's leave it to them and give.
There are a lot of families like us
We need shelter.
We have no food.
We don't know what to do tonight.
We eat for lunch.
And what we will do tomorrow.
We've just lost everything.
Hussein shows us where he slept
with his surviving
children and grandchildren last night.
Do you think there will be any help
coming from the military?
I don't believe
they will come to help us.
I would just have to struggle to feed
the six members of my
family that are left.
Myanmar's junta leader Min
Aung Hlaing,
visited the same hard
hit area Sittwe on Monday.
He promised aid from the military,
but the U.N.
and many international aid organizations
say they have been heavily restricted
from entering the country
and different to rule
since they seized power two years ago,
leaving the residents of Rakhine.
Many living in camps
to fend for themselves.
The storms completely destroyed our life
and bring us on the road again.
Already vulnerable communities
hoping for help that may never come.
Paula Hancocks, CNN.